from screen jumping studios in the heart
of Los Angeles this is screen junkies
movie fights now your host Andy signor
just kidding hello screen junkies and
welcome to movie fights I am NOT Andy
signor I am Spencer J Gilbert guest
hosting today because Andy was on a cell
phone right now demanded that he step
into the arena and fight for himself
this is a redux of the epic Dan V Andy
Jurassic world fight but this time it's
about Suicide Squad and there's a lot of
other great stuff on the menu today
we're talking who should direct Man of
Steel to what's the best Disney
live-action movie and the main event
Suicide Squad rotten or fresh if you
would like to join the conversation live
on Twitter hit us up hashtag movie
fights live let's get right to it and
meet our fighters today on my left he's
the boss he's the creator of honest
trailers regular host of this show the
judge with the most any signal I got my
tweet out so I okay good tune in that's
what I was doing okay god I make sure
people know we're doing this because
this is this is an important one yes
this is big that the fight between Dan
and I for Jurassic world is one of I
think the most iconic fights right how
uh you were both at the height of your
powers and to the left of Andy is the
icon himself the man also at the height
of his powers it's Hal retinic Spence
what's up glad to be here I came here to
chew bubblegum and kick ass and I'm all
out of bubblegum and to get quotes
backwards and then to the left of him it
is the champ himself dan the man Mauro
hi can I say before we even start this
is great this this is like I'm having
flashback to now this is like back when
we first started I don't know if we've
had a thousand Burbank
JT still in the booth
buthe Kenda's lurking creepily nearby
it's just like when we first started but
for some reason I'm hosting so uh quick
rules minor no you guys don't need it
but maybe for the people watching all
scoring is based on the facts presented
the passion and the creativity of your
arguments not based on what I like the
best which is a good thing because I
haven't seen Suicide Squad which brings
us to our first round Oh
[Music]
so starting off I am and how could I
forget the other man on the bench my
compatriot my brother-in-arms when it
comes to writing on his trailers mr.
Joestar
Spencer it's not the first time I'll be
forgotten to chop the last but I'm happy
to be here brother but something that
you learn about my judging style is the
facts don't matter but thank you for
being here anyways perfect all right
round 1 we are doing a special fight now
this is just between Andy and Dan house
recusing himself but he is gonna have a
chance to win some points he's gonna
vote on who he thinks will win this
argument and the argument is Suicide
Squad
Rawdon or fresh have you written down
your he knows I'm going I'm going fresh
ok I'm I'm going rod and Hal I will hold
on to this from Phil in a secret boat
the end of the round and you may begin
Andy start look this movie definitely
has some issues but I think what this
movie also has is a edgy risky fun movie
from the DCU that you can't
underestimate there there is so much fun
in this movie that I have things to go
through but I don't want to get bogged
down into I want to give a quick opening
statement you can't deny the fun you
can't deny the action you can't deny the
characters those are things that you
can't say is a is a bad movie when you
when you can hit those things out of the
park story can sometimes be bad I can
prove that I'm going to prove that your
honor but I'm defending here today that
suicide squad does not deserve all the
hate suicide squad was a fun ride that I
saw again twice sir and I present to
evidence the ticket stub for last night
which I paid for with
I own money to see again which I bet you
my competitor has not but this money
came from Marvel right that's your
opening statement dan let's hear it was
the movie the same as the first time you
saw it it was just as good
it was the same movie though yeah we say
moving justice guy I didn't need to go
see it again because I already saw it
and I have my points I don't know why
you trying to use that against me I
would like to note this is not funder
failure you said fun four times just in
that opening argument and again your
honor
attention I liked your run you basically
said and your opening our guy you said
is that it's fun it has action and
characters in it I cannot deny that it
has both action and characters in the
movie and I will also grant since we're
not doing funder failure and this I'm
gonna kill me I hate that phone or
failure thing I'm never arguing again
then yes this movie does have some fun
in it I liked this more for example the
Batman V Superman I like this movie more
however I'm going rotten and I'll tell
you why it's a mixed bag at best but I
think the mixed bag excuse heavily on
the negative sides I'm gonna go much
more into depth on my points here but
for example pace and editing does not
work in this movie it is all over the
place at a scattershot just as a story
it is not well told there are flashbacks
inserted that don't belong there there
put randomly at random points during the
movie it's very her key Turkey there's a
lot of montages that do not belong the
story doesn't flow the movie doesn't
flow it comes and goes it stops and
starts and it's really disconcerting to
watch because every time you start to
get into it I've cut to another
storyline that a seemingly random point
it's just kind of all over the place
it's scattered The Enchantress the
villain of the movie does not work one
of the worst villains in any comic book
movie that I've seen the third act is
the same generic sky beam faceless army
garbage finale that we've seen in
Fantastic Four that started with the
Avengers and now every other movie has
to do it that Ultron was doing with the
faceless army it's just empty action the
finale did not work at all for me the
tone of the movie shifts wildly it
started off you know especially the
first time we saw it this looked like it
was gonna be a dark movie at some times
it is a very dark movie but then out of
the blue it'll be a fun poppy movie with
a big Eminem song or whatever head to
the saw that stopped in the year 2000
they decided to do that day the tone
will shift just randomly seemingly at
random from dark to bright to dark to
bright to music that's it it's again I
think this is a story of a movie that
was reshot partially that they didn't
quite know what to do with the script
doesn't really have a through-line
it has it starts with a flashback it
starts with two flashbacks and then we
go to present-day and then takes us back
to a flashback there are characters that
don't track Captain Boomerang doesn't
really track what exactly they're doing
and why they're doing it doesn't exactly
track they don't successfully tell a
story from A to B the characters don't
exactly get their arcs and finally the
Joker first of all putting aside and
again this is opinion based putting
aside what you think of Jared Leto's
performance I didn't like it some people
do like it that's more of a matter of
opinion I think it's hard and I'm the
Joker himself is completely superfluous
to the movie he was not incorporated
into the movie well his actions don't
really have any consequence on the story
and again I think it is the case of a
flawed product maybe at one point he did
but this was a movie that seems to me it
came from a germ of a good idea it got
monkeyed around with and reshot and put
into a final piece that i will
acknowledge yes has some redeeming
qualities in it but if you're asking me
fresh or rotten I think is a movie as a
story it's not well told and the
negatives for me outweigh what the
positives might have been I'm hearing a
lot from day and we know that's a big
list is sounds so old like you're
talking about the story the story was
very clear to me you got him too dark to
light dark to light yes there was some
odd pacing but the movie is very clear
to follow every flashback they give
serves a purpose whether necessary or
not it's not Batman versus Superman
where they're going all their place with
these useless things
everything that whether you agree from
depending whether it right or work I
just disagree it does not the thing I
will give you is that this is the third
act the third act is a mess there's a
generic sky beam but my argument is
there so many movies that do that and
that doesn't deserve a rotten when that
that's just that just happens a lot of
superhero movies it's hard to fight to
have that final swing you go through I'm
trying to get because you'll a bit a lot
I just think you're off on the tone the
tone is the match of the trailer whether
that's right or wrong the trailer
company was involved in this editing
when I sat in it in a group full of
actual audience members they loved it
they were reacting positively they were
laughing they were saying that was a
great soundtrack I think we are being
filmed snobs by going so my new show
with our specifics we're
not be able to sit back and say this was
a ballsy move from DC this was evident
seeing these characters come to life and
I didn't just say fun the characters or
what makes this movie go over the edge
and I want to get specifics insight
since I didn't do my big list Deadshot
is amazing in this movie it's finally
the Will Smith throw out focus and seven
pounds and all this dumb nonsense that
Will Smith has been drowning us in this
is the Will Smith we love he's back
every time he's on screen he makes it he
makes stand-up moments like there's the
scene where he says am I gonna cut
that's how I cut and run the crowd went
wild like I went wow I got goosebumps
like every time Will Smith did something
it was stronger than I would think I
think actually any summer movie he was
probably favorite summer action hero of
the whole summer he was that strong
Harley Quinn watching the second time so
nuanced and so strong in her performance
that scene in the car were they where
she leaves you see actual despair in
there she's not just playing the
character turd that I think a lot of
people are accusing her for she's
fantastic
the Joker I wasn't a huge fan when I
left when I watched it again I agree
there's a little bit of a pacing there
but I understand why when you get Jared
Leto as the Joker he is doing something
more special there there is nuance to it
there is a Matic Ness to it that I think
sadly that is to have enough from the
time to show so you didn't really get to
see it but I totally see the germ of a
great Joker in there it's not the Heath
Ledger Joker because he just didn't get
a showcase he didn't get to showcase it
enough and there was a lot to tell but
the Joker was fantastic
all these you're saying Diablo fantastic
character they gave him an arc analyze
other people arcs and I thought was
really great it's kind of a weird arc
like always a gangbanger like is this a
good carrot but he's a villain and there
you see the the the conflict and of
murdering his family and then having to
lift out and stake yes they Russia's
third act at the end but it's it's an
action movie it's a popcorn movie then I
had a blast in and I think fun is
important here because sometimes when
you have enough fun it helps to justify
why it's a fresh okay so Andy you're
giving me a lot of good character stuff
dan what do you have to refute that I
don't think it's film snobby to point
out that it's that a movie story doesn't
work I don't think it's London Lobby I
wouldn't be more specific cuz I'll tell
you what I'll help you solve any problem
she didn't understand it's not that I
don't understood don't do that don't
call that thing
if you don't money you don't know let's
go to Joker meaningless to the movie his
actions had no consequence whatsoever on
the story itself and it's not held to
justify Hartley's I'm not gonna keep
talking or not showed up what what would
have been different about anything that
Harley Quinn did in that movie you if
you didn't understand who the Joker was
and a lot of mainstream people just mean
whatever you got you can't be the exam
is coming I'm different about Harley
Quinn who was the was the active
participant in the story what would have
been different
about what Harley Quinn did in the movie
if the Joker had not shown up at all
what would have been different I mean
what god was on the effects of them
because the Joker does have a backstory
everyone does have some recollection of
what the Joker is in knowing oh that's
who she's connected with it did help
form her a little bit
it's a oh she's crazy that's why she's
crazy because she's connected to the
Joker oh I don't know this joker yet but
I know the Joker and the Joker is crazy
and I believe why she was crazy I
believe where she's going it made her a
little bit more interesting and I wanted
to learn more see I thought that she was
interesting and I got to think that she
was crazy when she was hitting her head
on the cell besides there's a moments of
genuine you didn't know where where she
want to decide but I don't think that
her character in any way revolved around
the Joker I think again this is why it's
a your hobby slightly in the movie
exactly exactly buddy up in that one
part that your that's one thing that I
don't like is the fact but that's is
that symptomatic of how much do you want
to jam in this movie I don't want to get
hung up on the Joker what about this and
there's a mad one the Joker not
necessarily this movie it's part of the
reason this movie doesn't work is
because there's so many things trying to
mishmash and jam Captain Boomerang has
some fun stuff there's no development
given to his character it's actually
great really he's a comic relief croc
there's really no development given to
his character really funny katana is
portrayed in one two line round a male
Asian lead but her character her
character is given nothing to do and
knows episode 4 to mark exactly there's
15 characters in this movie and two of
them gets a run in Harley Quinn oh she
said
being that every character in Civil War
had an arc Slipknot is introduced with
one line of dialogue and 60 seconds
later learned tell me why that character
should have been in the movies there two
died I'm glad they didn't waste time
tell me more about him because he serves
a purpose in this story of showing them
that they really can die but that's why
there are a number of different reason
why they're mostly and you need someone
strong to die okay it's because this
movie I'm telling you I'm telling you
that the reason why none of these
characters work is because everyone's
giving short shrift except for the two
movie stars which are Harley Quinn will
semester Will Smith and Margot remand
awhile Amanda law is good luck in
writing romance right there aren't they
Jesus Christ we let me talk like that us
in this movie but again her character
does not have much to do she is great
Viola Davis is great the character of
Amanda Waller there's a scene where she
does something very dramatic the fact
that she would do that is not set up at
all the fact that she is that brutal is
not set up at all it took me out of the
movie it's disconcerting that she would
do something that brutal because again
the movie does not give these characters
enough time to breathe and not saying
there's nothing redeeming about this
movie but you cannot say that a movie
that has a in use you-you-you till you
said the third act is a mess the
flashbacks maybe they're not necessary
the Joker he didn't have enough time it
does look like the Joker to clarify you
said it is a problem of time a movie is
a spacing issue I don't think this is a
full-scale disaster all time when this
movie is bad it's really bad I didn't
hate this movie I didn't really like
this movie
there's a left-footer actually the cafe
you very nice voice for you but I hope
that both of these actors in the role
I'm and I see within sectors I just you
better get positive shoes I again but
I'm telling you that it's rotten because
as you would listen to what I'm saying
in Chinese egg whites record store
positives in this movie but the negative
one comment only comes I'll chance to
actually talk for it I get one thing I
wanna give you guys on track I've heard
enough about the characters I want Dan I
want you to make some rotten I don't
want you did but try to tell you if you
would let me talk I'm sure I'm just
trying we have to know to respond not
because it's a list and I don't give
time to make my list I feel like you're
forgive me for like five minutes we
started you can spit assignment I will
try to comment your comment everyone's
the same so we're talking over each
other but we got to both be able to talk
well that's I know that the rules change
when you're competing and nother trying
to listen and say something but when you
list ten things how am I going to
respond to ten thing you wait your turn
like everyone else right I feel like
I've listened to ten lab got a good
sense of where you guys stand on the
characters I want to circle back to the
plot slick wing what's rotten notice
I've been telling you 80 things that are
rotten day I want to give you a chance
to say what's wrong with the plot and
you said muddled a lot where's Andy said
this was a simple story to understand
I've seen the trailers it seems like bad
guys doing something good so where's
where's this muddle I don't think it's a
simple story understanding the reason
that it's muddled is and I'm sorry
especially that you haven't seen it
because I'm gonna get into a little bit
of a spoiler thing but you have the
Enchantress it's kind of its kind of set
up who she is they give her origin story
and I'll agree that Jim chanter sucked
yes
I'll kids I'm willing to give you that
the enchantress was awful she has the
side quick sidekick who ends up being
the big boss that they do battle with it
the movie it's not explained really who
he is how cool though with an shot can I
please tell chef school can I pay it's a
fight dan I'm not gonna guys love from
talking but I mean I'm listening to you
okay you have a chances the reason that
she doesn't work is because they never
really said it for motivation or what
she's doing exactly they send the
suicide squad to to pick up a high-value
target they say and that said in one
line they go to the city we don't know
where the city is we don't know of what
consequence the city is we never heard
of the city we don't know anyone in the
city they're shot down in a helicopter
by whom we don't know you know whatever
explain lands shooter they never explain
your sake Emily never usually shut down
they say that in the movie I saw it
there's a beam from the lasers of the
endo shot down by a machine gun it's not
a beam it's shot down by machine gun
it's the bits the arms of not Amanda
Waller's helicopter their helicopter the
one that Will Smith is shot down by an
Irish fires are they aliens or a gun
orange fire shoots down the helices a
suicide squad crash lands in the city by
the way there's over using my new show
there's no reason for them to crash on
in the city they just do for whatever
reason they go to get the hostage the
hostage turns out to be Amanda Waller
now I thought she was in Washington cuz
that's the last place they put her
character but now she's in this other
city that I don't really know what the
city is or what it means to the rest of
the plot and then for whatever reason
they decide okay we need to go see The
Enchantress The Enchantress is awful
it's the same terrible action finale
that you've seen in fan for stick and
all these bad mediocre comic-book movies
and all of these good things and he says
what's what and what's rotten what's
rotten you bring up dead shut and bring
up Harley Quinn and you bring up four
down below and Tommy a wallet I'm
telling you and I'm telling you that is
5 K I didn't like Joker t suppose I'd be
Clara brought up five characters there
but you are you acknowledging that the
pacing is off that it's metal that the
third act doesn't work their back toes
were muddled the flashbacks don't mean
anything their place meaninglessly and
it's not a film snob thing to say that
the movies rotting because it's not a
well-told story even a badly told story
listen fun things okay I told stone to
ask a question and well guess who's fun
to that really quick really quickly I
have one follow-up question that we do
final thoughts and then we'll judge oh
you want to be why does this cast work
as an ensemble that's okay that accused
me I'd like to respond that because
here's the problem yes you can get so
hung up on the plot and there is a plot
I followed the plot the plots fine the
plot is really about this team coming
together it's about what do you do with
the ragtag of villains who are out there
to sort of be these these on you know
unjustice heroes you wouldn't expect and
how do they do it it's a silly concept
but it works it's a fun out there
concept that I was I think it's a ballsy
choice by DC I think was fun to see
putting these villains they gave them a
fair justification is of course like but
they clearly have a bomb in their neck
and if they don't listen their hands may
well bomb in their neck they have a bomb
in their neck that if they don't listen
that that's how you keep the villains in
check and it made sense to me the old
battle-ax you have to plug this movie
it's fun it's fun but the trying to
explain the plot of movie is those guys
conflicted together having to go and
meet
together and get out of the prison and
do it to see these characters
interacting together and solve the crime
which it's like it's just it is a it's a
generic plot all of night but the
characters are an engineer but the
characters were valuable because I think
that's your glossing over the fact that
you did like a lot of the characters and
you'd watch them again
I think it's that's a huge mark of a
good movie a rotten movie like Last
Airbender or transformers and nothing
that's not true
did Deadpool and let's talk about the
plot of Deadpool it's a terrible plot
it's too compliant I don't think it does
yes it isn't it's intelligible it's is
scared to death sir don't whack you're
not want you know why they're fighting
you know what's happening you know
exactly why we're doing what they're
doing my point is there plenty of solid
but movies where you can go specific
nitpick why are they doing this and
you're ignoring the fact that there's a
lot of strong characters in a journey
Deadshot's arc is fantastic the even the
end and the back witnesses are the
eyewitnesses arc right he doesn't know
if he's good or bad he's struggling with
that internally he's got a kid who he's
got to provide for right we mean a great
scene where Batman cameos and stand
their kids stands in front of them and
he's going to choose he's gonna shoot at
Batman but the kids like don't do this
daddy and you instantly get connected to
him the bad guy was a hitman
I'm not gonna kill my daughter Batman
I'm gonna give myself to bat me because
I love her you see his internal struggle
and then at the end when that went
during that badge third average agree
there is a moment of glimmer for the
Enchantress each gives them their dural
that kartik awful gets us I thought it
was a great moment seeing what she
really wanted was the with the Joker's a
regular when she has the kids and you
see Will Smith with his kid and shooting
the Batman those moments to me were
actually worth more the arcs carrying
through and then Diablo is a little
rushed but I still like Diablo standing
up against that and saying this is this
isn't real we have to fight back
you saw the team unite and fight back
and that to me is what the story was
what the movie was it didn't matter who
the bad guy was it was about those lead
characters it was about the Suicide
Squad coming together having that fun
adventure that journey learning who they
are and they were a blast they were fun
they were great characters that you have
admitted they were fun and I'm not gonna
hung up on some I'm not thinking about
on these story points that I think a lot
movie the story of the movie Deadpool
has tons of that it's not true so no
exist not like that's engine dies the
last third outlet you like to it is it
dad but I'm my point is that doesn't
make it a failure that doesn't make it
run what would you what would you rate
out of 100 what would you give this
movie uh sixty that's a fresh eye that
is not yes it is that is not that is
fresh that is my wish
look it up Joe yeah will fact check that
but I'll take that as your final stage
man damn I'm sorry I would give it a D
given exceed Dan once upon a time not on
the [ __ ] run tomatoes I would give it
a D if I was grading it I would get a
c-minus or D that's your male Rock
master fail okay it's run so would you
what you're getting at that given an F
viola only Andy I've heard plenty he's
gonna take that say she way because I
said sixty I'm not judging on the
[ __ ] Roger score first I want to hear
but like you wouldn't give it an F no
okay so you give it a passing great if
my kid came up with a d-plus it's a you
know a little Jimmy you can do better
that's a fragile [ __ ] bands of watch
Jimmy that's not fresh and let's hear
your find another fight fresh it's a
friend it's not a fresh I'm gonna take
that Andy's last statement Dan wrap it
up okay I hate that you trying to
minimize it's like oh you're quibbling
over these little story details the plot
the structure that complete framework of
the movie does not work and that is not
a quibble that is not being a film snob
and it is not saying that I'm asking too
much that the movie makes sense that it
makes some cogent sense that just
because in this random assemblage of
scenes in this complete mismatch of a
reshot movie that there are some moments
of fun that serves to say like add
that's enough that's not enough that
doesn't make it fresh just because you
said fun 20 times you said you like
Deadshot and I do the characters you
said you said characters that there were
characters in it and that it was ballsy
and you said fun eighty times and I'm
not refuting any of that what I'm saying
is that the movie doesn't pass muster
because a few things that you like
doesn't make a fresh movie and when you
look at these bigger things and the fact
that you are admitting the tone is off
the third act doesn't work there's some
characters the jesters are into the
structure doesn't work the flashbacks
don't work you are admitting that all
these things don't work and saying like
but there's some fun things in it that
to me doesn't pass muster for a fresh
movie if the basic essential thing that
a movie should do is tell a good story
if it doesn't do that I'm sorry it's
rotten okay
I'm well I love you Dan I was fun was
fun I yeah we're all friends when the
kid over happens I think we diem oh we
gave him a bloodbath yet that was that
was excellent uh let's go to Joe first
for any any fact checks well I don't
know who they hate more me or Dan is
probably made well among five hundred
divorce people pulled communications
problems came out on top is the number
one reason marriages fail I was going to
say that really made sitting right here
made me feel like I was in my boyhood
hope you change your vote what now that
you've heard the arguments would you
change your phone you know what I'm
ride-or-die with my boat hmm we've got
some folks chiming in on Twitter they're
a little split on on who their side with
a lot of people call it out Andy for a
bit of a heel turn at Road ragers
I love watching angle turn new viewers
apparently a sustained heel presence at
Road Runner says I love watching Andy
and Dan disagree about a movie they're
like two sides of the same coin and our
own lawn says he disagrees with Andy on
this so much it makes him retro actively
hate sing Street fresh on Rotten
Tomatoes is between sixty and seventy
four percent oh that's not I was not
judging it on the Rotten Tomatoes scale
Dan I will not get hung up on the
semantics I will not hold you that I
will say it's sixty percent out of a
hundred as in like a DVD I will give you
the benefit of the doubt on that because
I'm sure if you knew you would have said
sixty or fifty nine judging of my scale
with the run tomatoes scale I don't want
this to be judgment in a cabbage if you
had known you would have gone under
sixty what if you had known that fresh
mint sixty would you've gone under six
lakh is this rotten okay I don't a judge
this on Rotten Tomatoes particular
technicalities we're saying rotten or
are fresh in the general sense yes you
guys both gave amazing argument well
done all around I I haven't seen this
movie and so I came in as a blank slate
and I heard so much for and against uh
everyone had a counter for everything
else to soup the superfluous Joker
versus the presence of Will Smith the
fun characters versus the unnecessary
nough some of the characters this was
really tough
I had to give it this is tough I had to
give it to the person who set their
standards the best who is less personal
in their opinion
and that is Dan I gotta go with Dan
because he set the expectations for what
works as a movie and it living up to or
failing as compared to the standard of a
movie whereas Andy was living up or
falling short of his own expectations
and because of that I'm giving it to the
madman Merle for the first point and not
quite done yet
on the score board we need to see where
mr. Rudnick's loyalty does a little
point right now Andy signor because I
felt similarly to Andy in my view of the
movie yeah that wasn't very much
technically fresh yeah and yeah you know
I'm gonna see it I you know you you gave
me enough that I am actually gonna go
see this movie
it doesn't matter doesn't matter we're
going with round two guys we can't stay
all day on Suicide Squad believe it or
not we are those we are sweating like
all day I said going into this I was
like I'm not gonna let any get under my
skin I'm mistaken you're slamming
collected no way you you you two
actually are the best at it you know how
to do it I think Dan is unrealistic
Squatch I was doing all that on purpose
I was interrupting on purpose I know you
were yeah you gonna it's expensive like
a [ __ ] pie I'm getting threatened you
get you shoot bottles back up look we're
today yes girl Munder cuz it kinda
pressure going good internet television
hell you can finally speak because the
question is regardless of the reception
Oh Reb too regardless of reception
Suicide Squad is a hit at the box office
so spills at SWT our Star Wars Republic
lucky want do you want to continue
franchise and let's pitch Suicide Squad
to is the question so up first actually
on this because they're only two let's
go with Dan first oh wow okay I'll go
first
how many ways and yes living there's a
cruise of all those birds about waiting
there's only two because there are two
in the last round we're going to start
the order over is this really important
how if you want go ahead care I don't
carry they haven't heard I'll say yeah
no matter you can mess with me or I know
I know what Spencer stressing about it
doesn't go for an hour okay or if you're
not ready we'll do that uh I am right
paint me a picture
amanda waller she is moving back and
forth between Gotham and Washington DC
she is manipulating these villains to
take out prime targets and the Suicide
Squad is working but just like with
drones just like with anything
controversial there is collateral damage
because they are not heroes
they do not care and one man one man
sees this happening and it is making him
furious that man is the Batman and the
Batman wants to take down the Suicide
Squad but he realizes that's going to be
tough to do by himself so he's enlisting
the Batman family welcome to the party
Robin welcome to the party
former Robin Nightwing the dead one
Nightwing in this got a young he's a lot
with you and welcome the mole that he
uses to infiltrate the Suicide Squad
Catwoman mm he goes to take down the
Suicide Squad from the inside and the
outside and Gotham City is their bloody
canvas okay be VSS got it all right so
Dan what do you got so mine starts again
sorry for the spoiler Spencer damn just
keep totally spoiling we should spoil I
mean I thought hopefully audiences seen
it as so Suicide Squad ends with the
Joker breaking Harley Quinn out of Belle
Reve out of the prison Sosua squad
Suicide Squad to which I'm assuming
happens after some kind of Batman movie
ends with it's the cold open Harley and
the Joker are on the run from the
Suicide Squad who have been dispatched
to retrieve Harley Quinn who's been
broken out they get cornered on the top
of a building and it's Harley and the
Joker and
hardly kind of grabs the Joker's hand
she's kind of resigned the fact that
they're gonna get cat the cot and she
says well at least we'll be together mr.
J and he goes like he stroked her face
in the creepy jared leto way and goes
sorry puddin and jumps off the building
leaving her there to a rescue chopper
because the Joker's always got a backup
plan to his backup totally ban the
chopper jumps like you know they got
everyone happy Joker he's always got
something up his sleeve he sort of
planes falling down it's quite a
trickster
anyway the Joker basically abandons
Harley to be captured by the Suicide
Squad so that's the cold-open Harley
Quinn has been recaptured and we pick up
with Harley Quinn back with the squad
and the squad is struggling despite the
fact that they were able to band
together to kind of defeat the
enchantress it's just not working
because these are such disparate
supervillains and there is a little bit
of conflict inside everybody's got their
own agenda Amanda Waller gives red flag
a directive get this group together or
she will blow everyone's head off his
included this initiative it's too
important it's too important for this to
fail like this is her black ops deep
squad she's put a lot on the line for
this if this fails like who she's asking
with this who's she Rick Flagg there
he's like the good guy that works for
her that's in charge of keeping controls
one good guy is a new Robocop plays a
trick for Joel what's a joke Academy but
their next mission turns out to be
personal the Joker has seized control of
a school and Gotham City and their
mission is to take out the Joker so now
not only is Harley Quinn separated from
the Joker she's now part of the Suicide
Squad and she has to now be part of the
squad that's going to take out the Joker
but she sees this as an opportunity to
betray the team and reunite with them so
of course they have you know the team is
still having trouble getting together
Deadshot Rick Flagg are clashing over
who leaves the team Harley still angry
that she's separating from the Joker
Captain Boomerang Jai Courtney gets a
little bit more to do he's kind of
looking out for his own self-interest
he's looking for a way that he can spend
this maybe escape maybe just try to take
a bigger part in this team he's tired of
being marginalized he used to be the
boss he's not anymore
Kitana hates being forced to fight with
all these villains she's got the sword
still with her dead husband in it
whatever that means and much like the
movie Killer Croc is also there
so just as Deadshot says that you know
what he's done he's walking away you
could blow my head off if you want flag
drops the bomb the school that the Joker
has taken over in Gotham it's his
daughter's school and
he has his daughters hot his daughter
Deadshot's daughter hostage so this is
the person that means the most to them
and he says that he wants the lives of
the suicide squad in exchange for the
life of Deadshot's daughter now Deadshot
doesn't hesitate because he knows that
he's gonna make the sacrifice it's his
daughter and he's able to rally the rest
of the squad to storm the school to
storm Joker's army and to end to try to
take out the Joker to save not only his
daughter's life but the rest of the kids
in the school okay oh oh sorry the last
part I have to have the whole thing
anyway so Deadshot Harley are kind of at
odds a little bit you know she's saying
like God don't blame mr. J that's just
the way he is and Deadshot is kind of
like you know this is the man you love
like how can you love a lunatic who
would do this and so this is kind of the
conflict between the two of them
Harley's kind of questioning her
feelings for the Joker finally we kind
of end as they're going through us or
storming through one by one the squad
members get this disabled Rick Flagg
basically the only ones that you have
left are at the end or Deadshot and
Harley we're kind of back where we began
we're on the roof Joker has dead shots
daughter and he's like alright give up
or you know I'm dropping her off the
building I'm going Harley approaches the
Joker you think that she's gonna betray
Deadshot and team back up with the Joker
but she doesn't because Deadshot has
gotten through to her and he's real
she's realized that she is in love with
a complete psychopath and seeing that
this person would kill uh kids school
full of kids this n doesn't kid that
means so much to this guy who she's come
to respect she goes up to him she's
doing a Harley thing she kind of seduces
him and the Joker's gonna go Harley get
over here now
get over here right now and kind of show
him cuz the Joker is really this is an
effed up relationship but he really
doesn't care anything for her
basically it here's how it is basically
it ends he's tried to get Harley over
there the Joker says at least we'll be
together which is what Harley said at
the beginning and Harley takes
Deadshot's daughter and goes sorry
puddin takes the kid jumps out of the
way Deadshot takes his shot shoots the
Joker he falls off the school and now
Harley which is what this character
needs to be anyway is free of the Joker
she's seen him for what he is she's her
own character now she's not tied to him
and the Suicide Squad is closer together
now because they have kind of finally
united under the fact that they may be
villains but they're still capable of
doing good killing off the Joker that's
a bold move cotton SEO
disappeared shot of any fell off a
building baby don't play fair pipe we'll
see okay Wow I don't know about you that
sounded so boring I was so lost I was
hell Danny what you got Suicide Squad in
a school to condemn kids no I did not
say dead kid ever there whatever he said
she might kill these kids hey brick it's
called stinks here uh yeah whatever
here's what I loved about Suicide Squad
it was fun right dumb fun here's what I
want to do I want to put these guys in
space here's what's gonna happen here's
my problem with the VC you right
I don't want I don't want them struck to
this universe it doesn't fit them I want
them to go have fun adventures where
we're not constantly worrying where's
Superman where's Batman how do we do
this so here's my pitch Suicide Squad
right there back in there back in the
prison they're all stuck back there's a
dock ship outside of the atmosphere that
Amanda Waller and her secret team are
like we don't know what this is this
isn't one of ours what's going on we got
to send someone up there to see it they
don't know who do we send that'll send
patsies know Superman's dead Spencer
looks like they send the patsies let's
send them up because we don't know you
know what that is and if they die so
what so we send that we suit them up and
we're going full-on crazy with this
these are your lasers this is your space
bat we're going all in I want to give
the gun hit embrace the fun guard that
this is your space man I want to embrace
the fun of what it is can have been
doing that like this is what this is
going to be your about zero gravity back
whatever it is let's just get them up
there to have the fun they are then
equipped put into space I don't need a
bunch of plot I'm a bunch of the story
to get us there I want to have them fun
we're getting them in a spaceship
launching them into this dock ship and
it's aliens with Suicide Squad they're
in this dock ship they don't know what's
going on
uh-oh it's the Dorian's that's right DC
I did some research and the Dorian's are
our random alien race that are going to
be there they were in the jail Justice
League of America issue three these guys
were tricking it we're gonna but this is
I'm too I'm Russian Allah unlike that
I'm gonna give you the pain points ahead
there's gonna be a lot of aliens there
it is look at it the deal DeLoreans
right route they would legally get up
space Spencer so the guard they thought
they were trapping the Justice League
but no the Dorian's accidentally effed
up and they caught the Suicide Squad so
now this is a
and again a robust your base and they're
gonna be going around having to do the
missions the door ends I got Lobo
showing up at one plug it season a
bounty hunter and another fellowship
guys we're going galactic let's take
these awesome fun characters let's just
have a silly get them get them there and
then let's have some damn fun for once
in this DC you so you go okay look like
this out yes I'd like to I'd like to
chime back in first of all Dan pitched
basically a bloated reworking of what we
already stronger less natural Oh that
real relationship with Harley and Joker
was exactly from the first movie on
shoes no absolutely I like you kept
talking about Oh Joker and Harley back
and forth that happened throughout this
movie that is it hey uh yes they're
gonna do that I don't want the Suicide
Squad you look you're really pitching
for the same and I'm not improved
positive pitching more that you were
pitching more the same you're part of
your pitch that you just gave you were
like Oh Deadshot is still this this guy
is still that you guys I'm sorry
salaices daughter oh no you were saying
these characters still have these same
issues from the first movies movie it
was an exploded version mine is an
advancement of the story okay you are
taking this group you are seeing them on
missions and there's an element of a
movie that really worked to my story I'm
sorry excuse me
it's can I tell ya I'll go ahead uh
Captain America Civil War there's a huge
Civil War stretch that's why correct me
if I'm wrong but I thought this was
Catwoman infiltrating the Suicide Squad
with Robins and yes first let me women
let me tell you why in Captain America
Civil War the sokovia accords
were to rein in this group of people
that were going around running roughshod
and causing collateral damage Batman is
doing his own version he wants to stop
this group that villains turned hero
that are going around causing a lot of
collateral damage it has the same idea
of power going unchecked to it and
Batman is I want Batman and Justice
League
okay oh if you can't do the Justice
League because the Justice League
you can easily do the Batman family you
can't do the Justice League cuz the
Justice League would wipe out the
Suicide Squad I just think we're near
this movie anymore I don't know I don't
want daddy like you'll do his own thing
and actually I don't want the Joker in
these movies either and one day you all
have grudges against Batman let's get
those going together them let's go have
fun with this like their doing and let's
actually yeah but that's your bananas
your bananas story this [ __ ] and I once
again got caught up on this film snob
thing called story which is that I
pitched the sequel that actually kind of
advanced the story particularly of
Harley Quinn and gave her a very
important character development you
somehow made it the franchise worse than
it already is you made them from kind of
being guardians of the galaxy to just
the guardians of the galaxy and I again
with here's how the last thing I think
this needs is more characters and you
just double the number of characters and
we just had a movie they had trouble
giving the characters that they have in
order to do fun and yours Dan because
you even acknowledge this movie had some
fun hey this movie had some fun you
still have those it's not 12 the
explanation regards I said there's an
extra scene and I think this thing all
rights to be darker don't worry Dan
you're the only one that pinched an
actual movie you get the place now you
hear what I get you touch the premise if
it's just set up I didn't hear enough of
the movie I have more of them they
knocked you down with the with too many
characters I didn't get the Civil War
comparison and Andy years does sound fun
but what the failures stench is - and
ray dealing with the same issues I mean
that's a that's a good critique but not
good enough because every superhero
deals with their same issues in every
single one of their sequels there's core
struggles you were rushing him along too
you know you were bored he's don't admit
it
oh yeah but I definitely know so if you
guys have stronger pitches he could have
taken down fans but knocking him down
didn't give you guys a movie pick some
weird oh man and she had to mention my
third act I would have chosen yours to
howl over that well that's for another
episode guys
we are moving on to non Suicide Squad
really anyway finally poof all right at
the only d-pad ass it appears as though
Warner Bros has begun development on Man
of Steel - how we're still doing this
so Daniel Patterson asked who would be
your ultimate Man of Steel - director
and I guess if we're throwing the order
out then you can begin with that me okay
I went with Brad Bird I think that first
of all I think the Iron Giant is a great
proof that that was a movie that had to
do tangentially what's not a Superman
movie but had to do with Superman and I
think it kind of proved that he sort of
gets what the character is about I think
you know secondly despite what you
thought of Tomorrowland is a movie which
you know Tomorrowland admittedly didn't
do great but I think that it had some
really great ideas I think that the
style of it it was really is really kind
of a fantastic I liked it was a very
original visual style that he brought to
that movie and I think what Superman
needs right now is a director who can
bring an interesting visual style of
movie but also understands the character
and isn't afraid to mix in to get that
mix of you know the inspirational
hopeful things but that can go to those
darker places that can go to the
sentimental places the Iron Giant
from a certain point of view is a very
dark movie from the other end of it
though it's also very inspirational it's
very hopeful so I don't think you need
to change tones completely I think you
have a directive that can bring
something different that gets the
character I think that we have a
Superman who's coming off of I assume
being resurrected and this is gonna be
his first solo movie back so I think
there can be a subtle shift in the way
that the characters treated and I think
the Brad Bird would be a great fit for
it okay Superman
uh that brings it to Andy who's your
ultimate man to steal pitch for director
it's richard donner man i want to bring
them back I want to put it some hope and
some happiness and some some heart in
this movie I think yes we can still have
gritty DCU I'm not saying that's a bad
thing but I think you can have one hero
who has a little bit more heart and I
think he established it early and I
think he continued to do fantastic
movies if you leave a weapon and beyond
that I think there's a George Miller
turn there I think he could totally come
back from retirement with the help of
others to really pull crush that out of
the world I'm not saying I want his
Superman back but I want a little bit of
his heart and his take on things too
rien rien ject that franchise just like
George Miller did with Mad Max and I
think that's how you do it and I don't
think Brad Bird or these people are
gonna be I don't want to stick them in
more brothers right now I want someone
who's going to maybe be a little bit
more legacy who's gonna get that respect
that Warner Brothers like okay fine what
we have to listen to you versus Brad
Bird get his hair pulled out at least
hooded people dealing with sort of the
conflicts in studio a pressure that's
going to happen so for going ultimate
he's available I bet you we could talk
him into it I can give you more points
as to why it's great but I'm going
marathoner ID with the number to his old
age home so you a just the director
should be Matthew Vaughn absolutely no
one's on a winning streak like Matthew
Vaughn kick-ass x-men first class
Kingsman Wow not only can he deal with
giving characters backstories giving
telling a good story showing characters
that are three-dimensional with heart
but man he is he has stepped into the
comic book world several times now and
knocked it out of the park so he's he's
well versed in that Action Man
the guy directs the crap out of action
uh big set piece action movies and how
about that fight in the bar and Kingsman
Matthew Vaughn is really one of our
finest action directors he would and not
only could he direct the crap out of
this movie his movies have a joy his
movies have life kick-ass is such an
intense story we saw what happens with
kick-ass when it's in the hands
one else it becomes a really violent
mess but Matthew Vaughn directing that
first kick-ass added a - water vivre -
it just died adds fun and joy to all
these projects that's what Superman
needs an ounce of all right guys all
around totally off I feel like we
already have a great action director
he's been doing Superman movies in that
Zack Snyder I kind of refer to Matthew
Vaughn it's slightly classier Zack
Snyder he's got a great visual style and
he's created action but we've already
done that with Superman I don't think we
need to do that again because acts later
record is is a savant annihilation every
movie that's not Superman style I don't
want I love taps on plain one how would
it give me more aside from just list his
movies okay in these movies in kick ass
in Kingsman there was a real light there
was a brightness that's what Superman's
missing Richard Donner if you brought
yes it's all the edgy vagina I mean he's
like the raunchy like it was dibs those
are so extreme and gory what's the like
you see he did it Kingsman on a butt sex
joke yes I'm saying I got ya the light
no I'm gonna do that no it's it's got
the action but also Colin Firth and eggy
and those characters are outside you
have it daddy for battery please can we
go through all the moves of Richard
Donner's - OH - six years old and that
is from a classic affair and let me make
the important point the most emotion and
he hasn't directed a movie in ten years
but the most important point is that
that tone would not work you want to
bring back that old 99 Oh super 8 which
is güell I don't just know he's made
current-day movies and George Miller
years ago no yeah but does George Miller
last live-action movie was babe pig in
the city in 1998 before Mad Max so for
the record you're wrong and I think it's
very Aegeus and unfair for us to say
he's old he can't do a movie again there
is an icon okay it was made fantastic
movies threshold Creek series art
I
you're not timeline was a recent movie
that looked like a present-day every
move over 10 years Inspira c13 it
doesn't matter those are not that 80's
era Superman all I'm trying to pull my
issues not with Richard Donner his age
or how long it's been since directed a
movie it's with Superman Returns that's
that was a modern-day Richard on a dad
but that would it may as well have
that's not what I'm saying
yes I made bet to say that he's gonna
radically change everything we know
about his directorial style that was
made in the style of Donner and it
didn't quite work and he's already had
his chance to put his mark on the
Superman franchise and he did and that's
great he gave us a Superman that's still
there that we love I want someone who's
gonna bring a fresh and original take
and that's why Brad Bird I think it has
that like not gonna freshen it already
no yes mother incredible is it is a way
to do it as one anime whether it's an
animated movie you talk about it's
better than kind of him saying I think
he's got the brightness that you want I
think Matthew Vaughn like I said we
already have a great invented visual
action director doses and I'm not I
don't see these films are intelligent
Matthew Vaughn's cannot direct live at
oh that burns director ken a live-action
Obie I guess I can't does not I can't
either I guess anyone else guitar um
everybody can't all no not over there
when you just yell when we try to talk
oh you yelled your way to the first
world yelling for the recto or a house
talking is not necessarily helping
Tomorrowland was not a good example for
anybody to ever find and good again
credible z' is a fantastic fringes that
I want him to do more of and actually I
wanted a time that says you can't do
what I want him to tell more original
stories and not get stuck in Warner
Brothers what do you have a view
incredible so tell more original stories
which one is it because one it was the
original story but essential to his
characters that he created and I want to
see those original character and he keep
doing this is he can add Julie to an
interesting new story he could keep
going around a to a two or three and
four if he wants to but I don't it when
he did the original the live-action film
Tomorrowland was a mess it was not this
great was a mess the script he was let
down by the script the movie itself
I felt looked great it had a great new
visual inventive style into one point it
was one of the most optimistic movies
that I've seen in a long time and that's
what Superman needs is optimism
Tomorrowland may not have been a great
movie there were stories there structure
issues I'm not gonna say he's blameless
but it had an optimism I don't see him
that now I'll give you a final point and
then but also
with vinyls yeah these are finals and
then end with why the other directors
would not make a good Superman director
absolutely well the point to what Dan
was saying about the visual style of
tomorrow and yeah we already have
someone who specializes in a visual
style that Zack Snyder's only saving
grace Brad Bird is only directed to
live-action films you get basically I
wouldn't I don't know if he can handle
the intensity of Superman he's brilliant
don't get me wrong he's brilliant but
Superman is that's the set pieces the
action the story uh he's failed with one
of his movies and he made a Mission
Impossible movie which is cookie cutter
at this point Matthew Vaughn has is up
he's on a three movie winning streak his
movies have action humor heart and
excitement he would know well enough not
to end Superman with a butt joke that
worked for Kingsman okay I think he's a
smart enough filmmaker not to want be
wildly divergent from the necessary tone
that's a silly point and Richard Donner
he's got a great filmography hey
everybody loves Lethal Weapon but it's
just not realistic plus the tone of his
early movies is wildly divergent from
what the DCU has established Matthew
Vaughn I would be so excited if he took
the reins
because again heart excitement action
humor alright okay good I think I get
why you each picked your own but I want
to hear the case against so Dan for your
thoughts oh yeah yeah my case against
Matthew Vaughn I love his visual style I
just don't think it's right for Superman
all of his movies have had a harder edge
to them even x-men first class had the
darkness had the Holocaust had all that
stuff in it that I don't think is going
to have much of a place in the Superman
universe I'm not saying that he's a bad
director I just don't think that his
style I don't think that his tempo and
his pace is great for what we need for
Superman Richard Donner apart from the
fact that he hasn't worked in the studio
system for a while I'm not going to use
that against them I think it's something
that you could factor in but I just feel
like right now what Warner Brothers
desperately needs to do is to look
forward and find the next person who's
going to bring something new to it not
look backwards and I don't think I agree
with how the sense that the style that
Don are brought to the Superman movies
is great and it works for them I don't
would work today and I don't think it
would be fair to expect him to
completely adjust his entire directorial
philosophy I think that you know of
everybody that's been pitch I think Brad
Bird is the one that that most combines
the tone the style and just a fresh take
on the character all right Andy look I
like Brad Bird a lot he's just done this
before especially more present-day
movies I think even Iron Giant and
Incredibles show us his Superman movies
and I love Bradburn I'd love to see him
do more I think Tomorrowland was a
misstep that makes me worried about what
he can handle and honestly I wanted to
make another Incredibles movies and I
wanted to go make something original
because I think he's a talent that like
Richard Donner and these movies have
done it I want to see him make his
lethal weapons in his movies and build
up that filmography before resorting to
another franchise like you do with
Mission Impossible which is fine I don't
I think we I want to see him do more and
I don't want to see him get stuck in
this Warner Brothers system and with
Matthew Vaughn II just totally totally
wrong it's exactly the problems what
these movies are you can say oh he can
do others I'm sure you can but he's not
choosing to do that and all the movies
he does he chooses to go that's sort of
more graphic darker approach even with
x-men and I just don't think that's what
Superman needs right now Superman needs
someone who can reborn him who can bring
it back and I think it is unfair to say
oh he hasn't done it in a while he can't
do it George Miller proved that can
happen and to say is too old or you
can't do it because of some ography is
completely unfair I think his
filmography proves for the fact that he
can make a strong movie and movies
aren't just based on the director a
director hires a great visual artist
hires a great cinematographer it's a
team effort when you make a movie and
someone may be of his age could easily
find people he thinks are going to
really make that vision that he has work
and I think we could use it I think its
iconic Lee a strong move for them to say
we're going to step back and try and
save this Superman and make him the
actual man of hope all right strong
round all around I would watch all those
movies I'd see all their Superman movies
but I'm not gonna forget you this time
Joe what what's going on the fan camp
it's also probably polls right if we've
done any the polls now let's recap a
little bit rotten or fresh we're split
down the middle the screen junkies
Universe is Florida right now 49%
51% fresh that's evolved since you did
your poll yeah even when it came out
Wow Wow Wow it's divisive that's why I
did it but down the middle and of course
I really think Warner Brothers wants
their films to be that divisive moving
forward positive way to market round to
pitch Suicide Squad 45% bat fan vs.
Suicide Squad now took it
18% Suicide Squad of the galaxy the last
space yeah that was last route that was
your sequel pitch 80% was below Staggs I
swap I'll let you eat it first and then
we can do a the Twitter poll for this
one let's see here George Miller was 70
when he directed Mad Max fury road
donors currently 86 his last movie was
16 blocks in 2006 Dutch movie guide says
on Twitter Donner has made his Superman
word on with him I see what you did
there Dutch guy well done dawn and Shawn
Barney says Christopher Nolan hmm I
think we kind of got that West yeah we
yeah I didn't want to do it and project
Devon says Kathryn Bigelow which is a
cool choice and at Andy Schick says
gentlemen raise your drinks the next
question is the 1000th movie fights
question congratulations what an honor
Andrew Schick actually he is the movie
fights tap master he is anyway he if he
says it I believe it that's awesome
I think I'm ranked 146 right now a long
climb but as regards to the 999th movie
fights question again strong picks all
around and how I'm sorry they knocked
you down too much with the tone I don't
see the comparison between kick-ass and
and Kingsman and Superman I'm just not
seeing the joy there a Dan and Andy both
really strong cases how you said that
that Donner was two divergent from the
DC Universe but maybe that's a good
thing for Superman at this point there
were some good points against Dan that
Brad Bird maybe can't direct live-action
and we want him to stick to original
stuff but I do love an Iron Giant
Superman yet that's kind of his real but
man and you just countered the
ageism and inexperience arguments so
beautifully with George Miller and
saying that he can get people around and
that's not what a director does and he's
proven that he can take his old
franchise and rehabilitate it I thought
it was a dumb pic but I'm going with
Richard Donner boom nicely done
you're on the board not a goose egg all
right but it's not over yet because this
one's gonna go long guys
buckle up you two our lunch wood wine
use and gotten the got realizing when
you when you're sitting here fighting
you feel like you're not getting your
words out yeah did you realize that one
four minutes apologize when you yell at
us it doesn't feel like that when you're
fighting it does well so this will be a
speed round round four submitted by
Aaron five zero and this is good because
I don't really like Disney movies so
I'll make this one quick they're doing
full speed ahead with their slate of
live-action movies so Anthony Riedl asks
what is the best Disney live-action
movie I forgot who I started with last
time I think it's big I started last
time so far it's Annie it's hands down
Mary Poppins I mean all these other
movies that are going to be said are
great movies but one to find it all it
was dismal Disney himself savoring
it's a hundred percent certified fresh
on Ron Tomatoes it has 12 Oscar
nominations for Best Picture director
etc five wins Julie Andrews the music
sound editing VFX two Grammys this movie
defined generation I think it defined a
whole class of movies it's a beautifully
told movie so creatively told
beautifully made wonderfully acted songs
that will never leave your brain and I
just think it's just a fantastic film
that you can't discount it's easily
Disney's best live-action movie okay how
no it's not because Disney's best
live-action movie his Pirates of the
Caribbean curse of the Black Pearl
that's the first one the first one yes
the first of the Pirates franchise
Johnny Depp's Captain Jack Sparrow
BAM instantly became part of our
cultural vernacular an iconic film
character if you will um and not a bad
cast to go along with that Keira
Knightley
Orlando Bloom were delightful Geoffrey
Rush as the villain was frightening Anna
Mae
and that fight on that wheel as as
they're going through the ocean is
mind-blowing and it's a very good movie
at 79 percent on Rotten Tomatoes and it
made over 60 I've made over six hundred
million dollars just domestically it's a
major hit and it stepped the game up it
show it made Disney relevant in the
live-action realm again okay it was
really a game-changing movie and it's
what you call a four-quadrant movie it's
a movie that appeals to young old male
female
everyone loves a man and so much so the
rest of the franchise which I'm not
talking about but like off that good
well I just went and saw with my mom and
we both had a good time you know anyone
and everyone can go see these movies
what a joy ride that Pirates of the
Caribbean
it is absolutely them what do we want
from Disney we want fun we want
something that is a magical Joyride of
fantasy Pirates of the Caribbean is the
best of live-action Disney Yoho Yoho
alright Dan what do you got I respect
both of your choices but I actually
picked the best Disney live-action movie
of all time
it's The Rocketeer The Rocketeer was the
MCU beginner before there was an MCU it
was before the comic-book bubble it's a
Rocketeer I made today I think it would
be a massive hit it has one of the best
scores for any movie ever by James
Horner it has one of the best villains
and any movie other Timothy Dalton as
Neville Sinclair the Nazi double agent
slash actor it's one of the great like
amazing just joyously evil villain
performances how I'm gonna borrow your
phrase here Jennifer Connelly at the
height of her powers and it's a great
relatable tale it's an everyman
who finds a rocket pack and gets to
become a superhero like who can't relate
to that who wouldn't want that to happen
to them it's so joyful and and and
perfect it's a cliff it's cliff fitting
to Secord and you have alan arkin is so
great but the fact that the character
cliff he gets to become this kind of
like mythic superhero and defeat Nazis
and and evil it's such a great throwback
to the 1940 cereals and
just drips with like joy and enthusiasm
it's it's an unappreciated movie it for
a movie that didn't do as well as it did
for it to still to 20 plus years later
be as relevant as it is they're just I
think announced a possible follow-up to
it I think it's a movie that's grown
with age it's a movie that stood the
test of time it's my personal favorite
and I think it's just a fantastic just
joyful little gem of a movie all right
tear apart these classics guys think jaw
Pirates of the Caribbean he even made
the joke Spencer did is that that's the
first one right I mean I cannot tell you
which we're just talking about the first
but I my point is they're all the same
is what I'm trying to get it I know
they're to the Caribbean or not to me
the success of that movie is Johnny Depp
that movie I can't you even said the
scene with the wheels like was that part
1 or part 2 I just think they all blend
together and in it they're a fun romp
I'm not knocking the movie the first one
is fun but I just I would argue and
challenge and I don't think enough
people really remember which ones which
I think they all would say that's the
best performance that's because there's
been a strong performance there have
been four of them I think that happens
they all blur together they're all
pirate ship cliches it's all yo-ho-ho yo
shorty yo ho it's like it just starts
getting so repeating yourself back to
2003 when it came out it was a cultural
phenomenon my dad was well Johnny Depp
was a clogger moon on and on the movie
was a box office it was a sexy country
jobs of Johnny Depp lack of Elliott
Johnny Depp's Oh fantastic turn and
that's what saved that movie it's not
the best movie I would argue Rocketeer
ism way better movie than pipe
disagreeing because Rocketeer doesn't
hold up the special effects don't hold
up every time the special effects wasn't
a hit it didn't work it doesn't find its
audience if this was best underrated
live-action Disney movie I'd give it to
Rocketeer but you can't put Rockets
Europe next Mary Poppins and they hope
they can / they're not even close it's
that sure it's fun I agree it's a fun
movie I liked as a kid but it didn't
pave anything it didn't do anything for
Disney was a huge bomb for Disney yeah
you can't ignore them do with the
quality of the movie Shawshank
Redemption was a huge bomb The Wizard of
Oz was a huge bomb It's a Wonderful Life
was a huge bomb to say it's hip to throw
back like oh well it was a huge bomb
that doesn't mean it can't be a great
movie and that's what it is it is grown
in your movie like minutes not a movie
it is a known movie and the Shawshank
Redemption became a very popular sell
high selling video The Rocketeer did it
we're not arguing what's the most
successful I'm arguing the best one and
out of all the
this is the one that I would watch
absolutely right now mary poppins
absolutely watch it came out in the 60s
julie andrews won an Oscar you it did
win a lot of awards but before watch it
they watch clips from its own mercy
cottage watch that I'm sorry when I
start someplace you start singing
tuppence I sigh snooze it inspires
omission pathetic great part Harry
bobbins one of the best Simpson episodes
I'm not gonna like I'm not gonna kill
that there are certain parts of sound of
music and Mary Poppins that are easy to
confuse Mary Poppins has not aged one
has her two years it was an early it was
a hassle eh ever seen it how it helps up
very well yeah when I was a very
successful primary some years ago great
that's great I'll go see it on Broadway
but I don't want to pop it on the on the
tea that you should see because it's a
beautiful story it's not a kids movie
it's not about saving the kids they even
did a remake about it it's about saving
the adults these adults who have their
kids stuck and and you think Mary
Poppins is coming to save these kids and
oh the kids are in this poor it's Amex
it's a really no it's a really deep
strong tale because the parents are too
busy they're not snot and chalice oh
let's go let's go fly kites yeah it's a
very powerful strong movie what was it I
was a guy who was laughing and floating
in the air and the Dyke is that no
there's another guy Edwin Mike Carlson's
favorite guy right Edwin he's in that
movie he's jumping around its sincere
dirt finally doing it they're doing a
sequel with Lynn Moran Randhawa and what
is Miranda
Everton must be is still popular
franchises parts of that movie that are
great I'll grant you but there's a lot
of that movie that's a little hit or
miss I'm just saying my pirate pirates
has the critical success and the by fin
success and it was a game changer
rollicking adventure that is second I
think Pirates was an average action
movie that was elevated by a great
performer yes its best movie but based
on a Disney ride you'd read hands-down
great performance um what about Geoffrey
Rush and Keira Knightley stole
everyone's heart oh come on she stole
everyone's heart Bend It Like Beckham we
all know that Keira Knightley missing
was to light their fire or Verbinski
knocked it out of the park for Connolly
stole my heart way more V I just think
the mind the best because it's it's such
a small eatable it's what everybody
dreams of it lays a locket you wanna
know because I like yours better you
have to have another boy guys there's
only so many hours in the day I could
listen to you all night that you every
day yeah but Joe let's go to you first
for the facts I did want to clarify what
was the wheel saying you were talking
about in parts of the Caribbean hell
isn't that particular - yeah yeah or -
is part one is when they're on this
they're from the CSUN man that's what I
meant yeah - they're on the seaside I
did this I met him in Geoffrey Rush I
didn't want another 10 min Orlando Bloom
yeah he does nobody Jagger
part-1 Disney's remake schedule got
brought up in this and I do want to
clarify I feel like just based on facts
that can't be a quality check indicator
they're remaking Pete's dragon they're
remaking almost their entire film slates
so Mary Poppins Rocketeer being remade
probably racketeers also a sequel rock
how is a sequel I was reasoning this is
not a remake they're saying I like
sister the same universe for freshmen
yeah she shared Disney Universe um let's
see your uh Mary Poppins be in there - a
similar time they go fly adjusted
box-office Poppins 102.3 million the
rocketeers not for inflation
this is inflation the Rocketeer forty
six point seven million Terminator 2
kind of tossed it out of the window
parts of the Caribbean uh one point zero
six six billion that's worldwide
worldwide very popular Wow okay man
damn it hell I was gonna go with you but
Jeffrey Rashi brings up a good point
that two of the things you mentioned
that were great we're not in Jim
pressures of the movie didn't fight each
other they didn't fight each other it's
just semantics the that's that's tough
that's really tough it's making it tough
okay I'll say you're still in the
running how's that but the guys Wow
how was the leader for me in the
clubhouse Mary Poppins you really gave a
good all-around argument that it's got a
lot going for it you argued a lot from
its statistics from its impressive
pedigree and the songs I didn't hear I'd
like to hear if tuppence really would
put Ben to sleep but otherwise I think
it's got some great music to it Dan your
your argument is so personal it was so
much of the things that Dan Merle loves
and you know the one I would watch and
I'm not sure if those effects look good
today
so this is a really this is like a
toss-up this is a 33 3333 toss-up for me
so oh man do I give it hell even though
he got the facts wrong I said the
beginning the facts don't matter how
you're still in the game I thought you
gave
our argument from the fire to the
Caribbean week thank you how to runner
Dan got that point guys L didn't even
know what movie was fighting yes I did
come on Twitter that was that was BS you
know it's but yeah you know listen I'll
show you I'll give you one defendant I
was that perfect guy to make things
interesting the office please Hanna says
Haley tells me to do that I know that's
incorrect no I wondered on the algae's
I'll give you one fact about that first
pirates movie the Cthulhu looking
octopuses yes I he was like I was about
mother [ __ ] is not come on I swear to
you we were talking about when we were
talking about earlier high seas where no
an that's what happens you're not making
it easy are that's what happens when you
guys jump on someone and don't let them
finish that's movie fights
well they finish imma let you finish but
I swear to you take the point of us
no absolutely if you're Ken we were we
talking about that earlier my son wasn't
hell joking is now at this hinges any
damage on from justice but al is the guy
I'm a lot of things when I'm not a
[ __ ] liar
but you do joke a lot I do joke a lot
Joe what do you think comedy or not no I
know what we have got jacket that was
the effects in The Rocketeer are still
pretty [ __ ] great Spencer okay I mean
that the squid guy wasn't in the river
he also do all right don't the way my
sword by Geoffrey Rush you did those you
did they did they played the applause
effect already
Mary Poppins is my favorite movie Kevin
I really love it from a personal reason
Wow
here's my
don't Risha I know I probably made a
dumb call but I think I already made it
so we're gonna keep moving on with the
show he'll take your stupid point you're
still in the game let's do this dumb
round wrap it doesn't in today though
okay here we go
this one's fun this one is literally
Russian roulette this one is restaurant
we're gonna keep this fast cuz party
over there nothing but bullets in the
gun yes this is Russia room where every
chamber is loaded and you guys are all
still in it for the end so let's see
what happens now this is a blind fight
we have five terrible movies in a cup
now where is this cup can nap sake thank
you sir you're the Vanna White of movie
fights
alright so nice pocket square we have
got five terrible movies in this fight
you will each pick one and then be
forced to defend it as if your life
depends on it
Andy would you be so this is where
arguing on why this is the best out of
the three right say we all grow this is
a movie
we all agreed to five terrible movies
that we all steam terrible we now have
to defend as if this is the best movie
though okay don't peek in the cup Andy
Wheel of Fate okay okay and a 1/4 saucer
so Dan you're gonna show you each say
what we're doing so we all know how to
argue this yes a first and then think
about what you're gonna say oh this is
great I got the last airbender I'm super
psyched guys I say are you though yeah
all right great uh how would you get I
got Fantastic Four for the record which
fantastic has been offensive 25:40 all
right Oh excellent
I got transformers age of extinction age
of extension Mark Wahlberg one correct
yes okay Wow all right Dan make the case
for the last airbender now it's over
these two right why I should watch The
Last Airbender over these two uh instead
our movie that's a good movie why it's a
good movie okay well yours first of all
you've got a night Shyamalan who say
what you will he said some missteps
still a very talented director talented
visually next you have an adaptation one
of the most beloved cartoon animated
series of all time now what The Last
Airbender does is take a lot of those
stories that you love condensed them
into one movie you're going to lose a
little bit in the adaptation short but
you still have great special effects
it's very visually
engaging movie I think that you have a
great villain in the piece it's a very
personal story with the villain and I
think that over these two is these two
are empty spectacle I think this one at
least has story it's got a heart it's
got characters that you can connect to
these are both just some Archie's you
forget them the second you leave the
theater unforgettable The Last Airbender
alright what else you got you won't
forget it yeah I believe it's your turn
how great so Fantastic Four is easily
the best movie out of these it took a
chance with the the origin story of
these characters you say it's from
beloved source material what more
beloved source material is there then
the Marvel's Fantastic Four and the the
personality that it really carved out
each of these characters and they were
played by some of our best young actors
you get to see miles teller and Michael
B Jordan kate mara what wonderful
performances there were in this movie
also it had such a great modernization
of the villain of Doctor Doom okay it
really put a modern spin on Doctor Doom
okay so that modernization bringing him
into the digital internet world that was
a real bold interesting take now we all
know that josh trank didn't get to fully
realize his vision but there's enough
there that easily makes this far and
away when you watch this movie you see
the struggle that these characters are
going through there are really beautiful
moments that get overshadowed when
people talk about Fantastic Four like
Michael B Jordan struggle when he's
becoming Human Torch how like ow
fire hurts when he's getting used to it
like no we take that really take that
for granted we really take that for
granted that the oh these superheroes
yeah they just get their powers and
they're fine in so many movies but this
has an evolution of them coming to terms
with their powers so it was a cool
interesting take on this story a great
origin story and yeah there's so much to
like look if there's one director that I
want to take my entire family to see you
went during the summer get some popcorn
and just have a great time it's michael
banck michael bay's one
the best action directors of all time he
knows how to make a crowd-pleaser and
this is his fourth entry into this film
you know what you're going to get and
you got amazing robot action but not
only that we got an Academy Award
nominated actor joining the fold in the
amazing Mark Wahlberg he's an inventor
he's can invent things I mean that just
took things to a new level he got to
help invent these transformers but let's
not forget this movie also finally drops
the Dinobots as a kid and that was
something I'd always dreamed about and I
got to see the Dinobots in action so I
can go on and on about why this movie is
a fantastic film I mean talk about also
diversifying they spent a lot of their
movie in China the China audience got to
be involved in this film which I think
is unfair a lot of the movies they don't
get to see a lot of our big-budget
movies but we got to really get them
involved in this movie and make this a
hit worldwide phenomenon that it is and
everyone's happy I have the best
director mind made the most money this
is the best movie Fantastic Four was a
train wreck Airbender completely
demolished its source material on M
night Shyamalan is a joke Michael Bay
baby all the way Michael Bay's not a
joke first of all if you're going with
the family angle what better way than to
take your kid to that fantastic summer
movie age of extinction and teach them
how they can also have sex with underage
girls yeah I grabbed lesson that age of
extends an important thing to know
because I don't want my kid to go to G I
don't 34 blue out of them second of all
when you're kids sometimes you make
mistakes right Spencer you want to know
what the laws like that you know the
dinobots are on screen for about five
minutes maybe five minutes
it does have China in it that's
somewhere in the third hour of the movie
I think I don't know a child that would
or could sit do that movie it is but
numbing Li oh look at the box on those
numbers it's the lowest when the you
elsevier it's grossing Transformers
moving air movie is completely offensive
to all races it took on yes it is it
cast a bunch of white actors and ethnic
roles which is completely inoffensive I
don't want take my family to that I
think that's whitewashing on offend
completely unfair of M night Shyamalan
who should know better and should cast
diverse talents out to John Day
laughter chime wind the you mentioned
China that was just a blatant cash-grab
China shoehorn that's unfair - ina yeah
I deserve to see our movies - they do
they see Oliver
yes but they want to be more involved
shoehorned China into the movie in an
uncomfortable way and it was so long you
talked about your film in such vague
terms I don't even question whether you
shot yeah so I I watched it for our M
night Shyamalan screen junkies episode
it made me want to slit my wrists I'm
know I reacted best about the movie was
I don't know I don't know plastic
doesn't get in this movie his name is on
he is the last airbender he knows how to
airbend it's a very powerful thing in
this world there's firebenders there's
like earth I don't want to hear the plot
answers I believe you asked me what the
plan was and I'm telling you what the
plot is and again this is something that
kids like it is actually kids movie not
like transformers which is definitely
not you talk about how your movie
started took chances it didn't it didn't
take a chance at all it wimped out
halfway through and made the worst third
act to any superhero movie I've seen
what was modern about Doctor Doom was at
the crash-test-dummy suit was the fact
that he got punched to death sometimes
going to learn he was invincible
that is completely it's a it's not even
a functional movie here's the halfway 3
to learn what's happening where do they
go let's have a fun it does have a
shredder tact but the build-up was
really satisfying and that was exciting
and seeing their origin stories and so
much of it was done well and they had
well cobbled relationships lasting hair
many loved as they grow behind 490 house
you lose a point for admitting faults no
I'm not a know any to mine my is the
best movie last airbender um it was
sleep-inducing it was so boring sorry
not a big all the way had a huge action
finale with the waves coming over like
the big ice walk that's a big actually
no sorry live dog just like I'm clearly
done talked about the entire third act
of your movie talked about your entire
no no no I'm telling you kids will enjoy
it it is something talking about the
color
Hallet of your movie last airbender very
go watch the show it it's vibrant oh
it's dour it's not down we're gonna be
amazed and so sweet I love that you
crackling you may have come with the
Fantastic Four who wear bright blue and
white costumes talk about add our color
palette I couldn't see your movie is
like it was shot on a brick of coal and
then projected on a black piece of
butcher paper into the Human Torch I can
see his fire perfect you take about
taking a vibrant a piece of material and
making a dower that's all your movie
dead that's the only trick your movie
had a lot of great moments talk about
the science - is one of the most
mind-numbing nowhere into a six hour too
long the other three changes what are
you expecting it's what you want when
you want this they've made four of these
for a reason because people go and see
these movies that's why it's the best
your movie was a complete train wreck it
was supposed to be a franchise and it
killed it both of your movies were
supposed to lead to more and they did
here - a fifth already in production
I'll tell you know one because I saw a
movie where we like I would love to tell
you why your movie is noise with good
branding okay that's all it is it's got
great branding that's why you're moving
so good rank on mine did at the bat what
he said probably seen Brandi Jessica
Morris great bring that they messed up
I'd take a forget landing the snow yeah
I'll tell you why cuz they scan it no
material right now I'm at least this
lectures we messed up the advertising
you all know that the studio screwed up
the advertising for fantastic you'll
laugh all pastic death yeah with the
advertisement so you're getting your
films not perfect I'm admitting the the
advertising the ad campaign but there's
all your dead [ __ ] on his mind maybe my
movie tonight kids show that kids
enjoyed and I made a Mumbai you can take
kids to that they will enjoy what else
would you want my dad kills don't come
to enjoy my but now green movie I don't
take a three-year-old a transformers or
your movie I take a 12 year old or a
seven-year-old you go to see transform
with resume 12 year old sit through Last
Airbender
they're not - my film had more redeeming
moments miles tellers friend the thing
their relationship growing up the
science fair that's the first 10 million
euros is so boring and ruins a friend
ruined a franchise and read a bunch of
fantastic characters that they shouldn't
that they completely may done fantastic
your movie the avatar is just
offensively bad the wooden acting
the script goes nowhere it's maybe yours
and kids enjoy is a fantastic ride it's
not having time to cry my mood is
fantastic right - whatever it is coming
from how finally found thought my movies
the only one with any redeeming value if
you realistically watch these three
movies this is the only one that has
character development real moments and
it sets up something very exciting and
there's great action throughout okay
good point Stan let's - let's break
these down realistically your movie
tried to be something it's a complete
failure it tried to be something
ambitious than it was sad at the end it
is a complete and utter failure
age of extinction it was color coming
amilia it's adults it's too stupid
through dollar it's too long for kids to
sit through last airbender it was a show
that kids enjoyed they made a movie the
kids enjoyed it was made for it I didn't
and it served that audience I'm there
but time they didn't enjoy it they did
not enjoy it I enjoy mine well whose
take we should bring a kid in here in 10
seconds box offices oh did you talk to
children this more no but I can go look
at the box office
okay good and the other movies that are
coming good fight guys good fight it's
already over but a Joe before I render
my decision any fact checks on that yes
Mark Wahlberg was nominated for an Oscar
for Best Performance did not win Andy
and this was also not the
highest-grossing Transformers movie
revenge of the Fallen arrow this out by
jillion dollars yes it's - hey Joe I've
never heard of the Oscar category best
performance best performance mess I
imagine five best performance by an
actor in a supporting role thank you sir
on a fight in a wheel okay
how long that point but he's not winning
this one I had to throw out the
criticisms and go for just the case made
for the movies which is an impossible
task I know because if you tear all
these apart and that has to go to Andy
you really the passion is part of the
argument and I actually believe that you
like transformers age do not after that
movie and I know you label art it was
both of theirs killing the franchise's
was a good point and we're still getting
Transformers movies
Dinobots your pro-china attitude I
really don't know that out of your ass
very impressive I'm called toxic [ __ ] I
could not you could not do it I can do
it I don't never go on record saying
this is a great movie that everybody's
gonna love and I'm gonna take my kids to
it I'm sorry I will lose that point
before I say that on the right and you
admitted false but this is about defied
away I never traditional Last Airbender
see only I couldn't finish we were doing
on this trail this will be sucked wow
yeah they all suck but you know what
doesn't suck garbage cheap oh man this
is around guys this is all tied up with
Andy and Dan going in this bad boy woof
so for those of you don't know I know
we're running long so I'll make this
quick you can earn five more points to
win the game
so I suppose its first two three wins in
this case it'll be an either/or question
it'll be an open question you'll have 20
seconds to answer then a 10 second
rebuttal or 20 seconds 20 seconds 10
seconds right 20 great here Joe will
help me keep time I will keep score and
the speed round begins now with our
first question submitted by US soccer
fan one this is a bargain bin question
so keep your eyes up on what you have to
cue it oh we don't have it yeah no this
is bargain bin picture doing out of the
picture so we don't have an have a ton
of the picture ugly I'll just tell you
alright guys I'll say it really fast
guys have a chance to us are we getting
it or no are you getting out okay why
don't you go to mine too
once you had a question - I'll give you
an alga pizza maybe we don't need it
yeah maybe Momo let's give that one my
women James go throw down me first
aren't you number two score still tied
this is a rematch but in honor of the
two-year anniversary of his passing
what's the best Robin Williams movie
Good Will Hunting Dead Poets Society
okay Dan Joe you ready
dan bigot I think Robin Williams is
people think of as the comedic actor but
it's the actor that I really want to
focus on it when I want to see a great
Robin Williams performance and when I
want to remember him finally it's Good
Will Hunting because he shows that
charisma so much what we love from him
in that comedies but we in the comedies
that he was in but he also showed that
serious side to him he showed the fact
that he was an amazing actor this was
the one that got him his Oscar finally
and I think it's the one - all right
Andy that was the show you're rolling
away and I think it was a earn because
they wanted to given the respect Dead
Poets Society is the one I think that
truly defines Robin Williams best
dramatic role it's a world that people
were inspired by that teacher they all
had that teacher it's one that they
really define him by I think it's
comedic it's dramatic it's the most
touching Google hunting felt like he got
the Oscar just because he was deserving
it was a fine role but it's more Ben
Affleck banana at Matt Damon's movie I
think that Dead Poets Society was a
great teacher movie classroom movie
we've had we've had Stan and deliver and
stuff like that Google hunting was very
personal movie it's the one that made me
feel most connected to him personally
not so much I felt well morta - Will
Hunting when I'm staying on my desk to
the teacher to tell him I connect that
to Robin Williams and his performance at
that board Society whoo
I seen that's time yes all right guys
let's go really quick - Hal and Joe -
help me out well I might have said good
morning Vietnam because I feel like
that's where he gets that stuff in the
show running time all right Pete why let
me go Jesse just for that dance oh this
might point for Dan all right Joe we got
a lot of I feel and I felt connected but
uh Good Will Hunting the one that gave
us uh the the only fact in here is that
that's we got the Oscar for so I got to
go with Good Will Hunting I was going to
go that way - not for the Oscar point
but it's relevant Dan you get the first
point thank you
all right three two - Dan on to the next
one twenty no peeking 25 movies because
for that by the way I know I was like a
Latin hood gonna be yeah alright
question number three / - who gives the
better performance isn't either/or
Patrick Stewart's Professor X or Ian
McKellen's magneto magneto alright that
gives you Professor X Dan you may begin
Ian McKellen's magneto is a really
complicated character that's what I love
about him as a villain is you can see
both sides the fact that he's family
went to the Holocaust that the fact you
can see why he's a villain why he hates
humanity so much Professor X has his
morals but magneto has the more
interesting backstory and I think the
Ian McKellen's performance portrays that
history that pain that is in his past
the fact Patrick's here has that same
pain it's his friendship with Magneto I
think makes it even stronger I think
Magneto's playing off of him even
stronger Patrick Stewart's fantastic
actor and unifies that whole team
together
I think he's so much more connected than
Magneto the magneto is connected to him
you wouldn't have the two without the
other Patrick Stewart I think is the
leader in that combination because he's
so strong as moral compass and whether
Charles will magneto is always the guy
that's driving the action he's the one
that's attacking humanity and it's the
motives of Magneto that you need to
understand Patrick Stewart great
activities reacting to what Ian
McKellen's doing in that movie McKellen
is one that's doing stuff Charles is in
hurt or turmoil of how to save this
villain friend is way more interesting
than magneto always having to go to the
villain trout and he always comes back
to Charles because Charles is the more
dynamic character and the board better
performance okay Wow tough stuff all
around how do you think well I was kind
of split because they're both good
arguments but in Dan's rebuttal go when
he mentioned that magneto really drives
the action and that adds another layer
to the performance I'm going with Dan
and Joe as much as I like my job
security I agree I've got to go with Dan
on that he has more to do as an actor
yeah maybe not the most fair question
but Dan you knocked it out of the park
how was I supposed to be Percy yeah I'm
shot I got McKellen
I really seven michael [ __ ] okay alright
so here let's keep this moving dan
you're leading with four to two any
question let's see if you can make this
interesting all right you guys ready
sure
okay who's the better director Clint
Eastwood or Mel Gibson took Eastwood Mel
Gibson okay and whenever you write
Eastwood's made more work I think Mel
Gibson's only quantified by Braveheart
which i think is a kind of an overrated
movie Eastwood gave us Million Dollar
Baby and from his early work to his
Unforgiven to it to his later work with
military baby and all this stuff he's
doing now so much more film so much more
iconic and he's not someone that I
personally have trouble doing I think it
does affect the argument a little bit
whether direct or not that's why he's
not directing you more personal feelings
aside Clint Eastwood has directed some
great movies but I find his style to be
a little static I feel like it's very
much just like a static camera uh Mel
Gibson is very kinetic style Braveheart
Apocalypto passion the Christ it is very
in your face is very visceral and for me
personally as a director I think when
you can show that kind of variety when
you can get in there and make those
different kinds of period movies when
you can manage things
visceral American sniper which he
brought that out of nowhere which I
couldn't believe he actually could have
that kind of tension happen now proves I
think he's would still Ken in the age
that he's doing is such a fan of
fantastic to Apocalypto is a mess
good stuff all right he'll help me out
it's tough but I gotta go Andy on this
one mmm okay
Eastwood over Gibson Joe uh yeah I'm
give it to Andy on this too he answered
the visceral challenge with a couple of
examples and then the body of work it's
an impressive argument thank you guys
for making my life so easy I think I
would have gone down there but you guys
outweigh me so uh Andy gets the point
and we have a surprise because the
bargain bin is now ready it's a good one
oh boy thank you guys for the heads up
so let's uh let's throw something up on
the screen these two movies are in the
bargain bin which do you buy just go
with it
hahaha can't wait to hear this
Andy argue first just go they'll
actually get some laughs in a bad way
because Sandler's premise is ridiculous
I don't think anyone and I don't believe
dan has seen Mordechai for a reason
that's why you'd never want to buy it
it's Johnny Depp at his worst character
spinless douche boom I did so over it
I'd rather see Adam Sandler and
attractive women like Kate Upton and
Jennifer Aniston and the sillies
shenanigans gonna have yeah that's every
Adam Sandler movie made for the last 20
years I don't want to go see another
Adam Sandler movie that I've already
seen seven times Mordecai Johnny Depp
love them or hate him you know what he's
always doing something interesting and
when I have to choose something I'm
gonna choose something that's
interesting to me that's at least gonna
amuse me when I watch it I don't want to
see the same rehashed Adam Sandler movie
that I saw the wedding singer at 50
first dates it's the same movie over and
over again actually did see it it's a
hate watch it's actually funny Mordecai
looks atrocious and the fact that
neither of a solid is telling me the
fact that I actually saw just go with it
which if I had a choice in a plane I'd
pick that one better because I don't
want to watch Johnny Depp do that
anymore
first of all you don't know if I see
Mordecai or not you're projecting that
on me secondly I will go with the
interesting new movie then the 18th
iteration of Adam Sandler wants to go on
vacation which is exactly what that
movie is you can easily ruin you saw if
I say move Wow
Danah you you won me over with the 18th
Adam Sandler movie vacation line at the
end I don't think I need to hear from
you guys but I'm gonna give that point
to Dan which makes you the winner I'm
surprisingly of movie fights way to go
Dan now jvc Mordecai right you'll never
know
guys that was - this is fun to get the
old game back together
sorry for overstaying our welcome if we
did without fun for me was it fun for
you yeah and finally people can stop
saying that
Andy sucks my pain and can start saying
that you suck my pain in the comments
cuz that's all they say than that what
he did how he gave hella courtesy people
was I'm the only thing that I will say
for the record I was saying it was in a
second anyway alright guys thank you so
much for watching guys were up for an
Emmy that's pretty cool right that's
awesome yeah we're going to take it away
place like nervous but won the Emmy to
my heart thanks to our guest today and
hey guys that's so funny in the ring
yeah isn't it fun no doesn't suck to
judge
Oh judging [ __ ] suck yeah but thank
you for coming on at Andy signor and the
Twitter creative Ron Australis as we
know mr. Hal Rudnick hi everybody hit me
up at how Rudnik Dan the champ merle and
your undefeated streak like that
exercised a year old Jurassic world
demon here today so yeah one now ready
there you go and and Joe star and the
fan cam I feel like we got to close this
out Twitter really wants a Mark Wahlberg
impression from Dan I feel like that
would make us all heal Dan take it away
two extinctions the best movies got me
I'm an adventurer and inventing so I
just make a bunch of things I invent
stuff I was nominated for an Oscar Joel
there's Best Supporting Actor for the
deported I talked like this in that
movie - alright guys take a trip to wall
burgers I'm Spencer Gilbert thank you
for sticking around and being patient
with me on my second job not easy but we
will be back Andy I'm sure we'll be back
in the hosting seat next time on another
episode of movie fights like every
podcast we put on YouTube comes with
this kick-ass graphic
listing all the topics your favorite
screen junkies podcasters are talking
about if you click the topics you can
skip around and choose your own podcast
battle royale go ahead try them all if
you haven't already subscribe to screen
junkies on youtube to join us for future
fights or if you prefer to listen on
itunes click the
go to download an audio version
you